die bundesliga macht sich auch am 25
spieltag für frieden in der ukraine
stark in allen stadien wie hier in
münchen werden klare zeichen gegen
russlands angriffskrieg gesetzt der
deutsche rekordmeister ist gegen
leverkusen in der ersten halben stunde
komplett überlegen niklas süle 18 minute
mit seinem ersten bundesliga tor seit 14
monaten
die werks-elf und die standards kein
team in der oberen tabellenhälfte ist
hier so anfällig
in der 36 minute schreibt thomas müller
geschichte in seinem 615 pflichtspiel
für die bayern unterläuft ihm doch
tatsächlich ein eigentor und was für
eins ein echter müller eben wenn schon
eigentor dann mit stil am ende ist es
ein leistungsgerechtes unentschieden
thomas müller gefällt das natürlich gar
nicht
domenico tedesco und christian streich
gratulieren sich gegenseitig zum einzug
ins pokal-halbfinale kopf an kopf auch
das rennen um die champions league
bleibt sich und freiburg mit jeweils 40
punkten der sportclub in blaue mauer
zwar kommt aber in der 38 minute zur
glücklichen führung hermelin demirovic
trifft wunderschönen gegen seinen ex
club
die gäste bleiben defensiv stabil in der
neunzigsten minute weiß andré linie
jedoch eine der ganz wenigen
unaufmerksamkeiten der freiburger
auszunutzen
leipzig und freiburg bleiben
tabellarisch auf augenhöhe
das peace-zeichen im mittelkreis und auf
der brust die solidarität mit der
ukraine ist auch in wolfsburg
omnipräsent
sportlich bleibt der vfl gegen union
berlin auf kurs klassenerhalt und dafür
braucht es nur einen treffer der jubel
ist aber der hat getroffen und zwar ins
eigene tor tajura bonn ein
schmeichelhafter sieg der erleichterung
tut das allerdings keinen abbruch
wolfsburg und vorfeld haben in den
letzten fünf bundesliga partien zehn
punkte geholt
duell der glücklosen in berlin hertha im
neuen jahr weiter sieglos frankfurt hat
dreimal zuletzt verloren und dabei kein
tor erzielt in der 17 minute platzt der
knoten ansgar knauf das zwanzigste
gegentor
2022 härter ist die schießbude der liga
die gastgeber sind anfällig und harmlos
kurz nach wiederanpfiff 2 zu 0 für die
eintracht
hertha ist völlig von der rolle langer
ball hinteregger torwart not geklärt vor
boni lindström aus guten 30 meter
wie sagt man so schön er ist kein glück
dann kam auch noch pech dazu
die komfortable führung lässt die sg auf
einmal in konsequent verteidigen joker
davie selke sorgte zwischenzeitlich für
das ganz zu 3 ein klasse tor aber nur
ein kurzer jubel der tabellensechzehnte
präsentiert sich insgesamt weiter wie
ein abstiegskandidat
raphael 63 10 minute zum endstand der
kolumbianer beendet seine torflaute und
erzielte sein siebtes saisontor vierte
niederlage in folge dafür für berlin und
tankwart
das topspiel am samstagabend ist ein
abstiegsduell adi hütter und borussia
mönchengladbach zu gast beim seit neun
spielen sieglosen vfb stuttgart das team
von pellegrino matera zu in weiß ist
deshalb die führung geht aber an die
fohlen
assam player in der 14 minute
neuhaus ganz fein in den rücken der
abwehr im mittelfeld ist gladbach
spielerisch an guten tagen eines der
besten teams der liga und das zeigt sich
auch beim 2 2 markus thorandt mehr als
eine halbe stunde gespielt
torschütze player glänzt auch als
vorbereiter mustergültig auf seinen
französischen landsmann
stuttgart weiß ich für viel einsatz und
willen vor der halbzeitpause zu belohnen
endo 38
l w die fälscht den schuss des japaners
für sommer unhaltbar ab
nach dem seitenwechsel stemmt sich der
vfb eindrucksvoll gegen die
sieglos-serie
zunächst karadzic führich ausgleich 51
liter
der vfb und 25.000 zuschauer sind on
fire stuttgart bleibt dran kommt über
den starken sosa
nochmals zu einer guten gelegenheit
karadzic 83 minute stuttgart rät hat
[Applaus]
gladbach lässt sich vom spiel als auch
von der kulisse zu stark beeindrucken
stuttgart feiert im abstiegskampf einen
befreiungsschlag
tabellenschlusslicht reuter führt hat
sich in der bundesliga stabilisiert der
erste auswärtssieg steht aber immer noch
auf der to-do-liste beim vfl bochum
gerät das kleeblatt in der 35 minute in
rückstand maxim balsam für seine seele
der verteidiger hatte unter der woche
mit seinem patzer das pokal-aus gegen
freiburg zu verantworten fehler sind
menschlich und eigentore der trend des
25 spieltags aml bella coach ab in der
64 minute
allerdings macht es keiner so schön wie
man
glück für führt aber nicht genug für den
ersten dreier in der ferne bochums
kapitän lucia ist das stadion feiern in
der 71 minute zu hause ist es eben am
schönsten bochum holt die meisten punkte
vor den eigenen fans
[Applaus]
am freitagabend rufen bielefeld und
augsburg zum spenden für die ukraine auf
der fußball und die welt halten
eindrucksvoll zusammen der fch in den
weißen trikots gewinnt aktuell 14
tägigen 15 dank des siegtreffers von
daniel caligiuri
ein tor erzielt den rest verteidigt so
geht abstiegskampf der fcz am direkten
konkurrenten vorbei
wegen der mainzer spielabsage gegen
dortmund ist köln gegen hoffenheim die
einzige sonntagspartie die gäste in blau
träumen vom fußball himmel champions
league der flankengott fall schon jetzt
unter ihnen david raum und sein füßchen
finden den kopf von stephan pusch zum
fünften mal in dieser saison führt eine
flanke von raum zu einem treffer und in
diesem fall auch zum sieg denn trotz
zahlreicher chancen auf beiden seiten
bleibt es bei dem einen tor in der 61
minute
das ergebnis spiegelt den 25 spieltag
wieder neben zwei unentschieden sind es
vor allem knappe resultate nur eintracht
frankfurt mit einem deutlichen 4
1-erfolg mainz dortmund wird am 16 märz
nachgeholt in der tabelle könnte der bvb
den ausrutscher der bayern also noch
ausnutzen das rennen um die
internationalen plätze bleibt spannend
in der zweiten hälfte hat sich wolfsburg
stabilisiert ab platz 13 wird die luft
dünner nach dem sieg ist beim vfb
stuttgart aber wieder große hoffnung
angesagt
[Musik]